[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين فرانس 24
على المباشر مع ما يقولون على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
نقاش هنا على الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا في ليله راس السنه
وعندما كان رئيس فلاديمير بوتين يعلن
محاطا بعسكريين ان هذه السنه ستكون سنه
الانتظار نفذ الجيش الاوكراني بواسطه
الصواريخ
عمليه ضد مقر لجنود دروس في ماكيا قرب
دونيتك الحصيله ثقيله ثمانيه وتسعون قتيله
همم الاف العديد من الانتقادات في وسائل
الاعلام ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الروسيه
للقياده العسكريه الى اي حد ما حصل يشكل
منعطفا خطيرا قد يزيد الطين بله او يرغم
الطرف الروسي على التفاوض دون شروط
تعجيزيه هل يمكن القول ان الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه الروسيه
انتظر وانه اوكرانيا اصبحت مستنقعا حقيقيه
نناقش الموضوع سعيد بان يكون معي هنا في
الاستوديو خطر ابو دياب استاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه سعيد بان يكون معنا من كاف
فولوديمير شوماكوف وهو دبلوماسي اوكراني
سابق وسعيد بان يكون معي من موسكو
اليكساندرز سكين وهو دبلوماسي روسي سابق
اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا نستمع لما
قاله الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
باحدث نظام صاروخي للفرد الصوتي الذي تفوق
سرعته سرعه الصوت في البحر السفينه كذلك
مجهزه باسلحه حديثه اخرى او ادو ان اشكر
المتخصصين في المجمع الصناعي العسكري
الذين طوروا هذا السلاح الذي ليس له منافس
على مستوى العالم
مثل هذه الاسلحه القويه ستحمل روسيا بشكل
فعال من التهديدات الخارجيه المحتمله
وستساعد على الدفاع عن المصالح الوطنيه
سنواصل تطوير القدرات القتاليه للقوات
المسلحه وانتاج اسلحه متطوره تحمي امنه
روسيا هذا سلاح وقعت اتمنى السفينه
التوفيق في خدمتهم لصالح الوطن
نستمر
نيا استباقا لانشطه التعبئه التي تخطط لها
الدوله الارهابيه وهذا بالتحديد الوقت
الذي يتعين علينا فيه مع شركائنا تعزيز
دفاعاتنا ليس لدينا ادنى شك في ان اسياد
روسيا الحاليين سوف يلقون كل ما تبقى
لديهم ويضحون باي شخص يستطيعون التضحيه به
لمحاوله السيطره على الوضع او على الاقل
تاخير هزيمتهم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ضربه القوات الاوكرانيه 6 صواريخ من نظام
نهائي
من قبل الولايات المتحده على نقطه انتشار
مؤقته لاحدى وحدات القوات المسلحه الروسيه
في مكيفك قرب دنياك قتل عشرات الجنود
الروس نتيجه هذه الضربات
سيتم تقديم كل المساعده
الان عن فشل الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
الروسيه في ظل ما حصل خاصه عندما نرى حجم
الانتقادات التي تتعرض لها القياده
العسكريه الروسيه
اه بالنسبه
في شبكه تواصل الاجتماعي او وفي
وسائل الاعلام الاخرى
كل واحد
يقيم ذلك
انه موضوعيه نحن الان اااه نشاهده مرحله
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
مرحله الاولى تقدم سريع روسي
المرحله الثانيه
مع الجبهه مستقره في المناطق الاساسيه في
نفس الوقت هناك في دمباز والسلام الله
الله
اشتباكات عنيفه وهناك التقدم بطيئه للجيش
الروسي اا ونحنا امام مرحله الثالثه هناك
التوقعات مختلف حول الموضوع
الجيش الاوكراني في حاله تمهيد للهجوم
بتصير الله خلال الفتره القريبه القادمه
[موسيقى]
او يكون مؤجر الا الربيع ولكن الشيء اكيد
انه نحن امام المرحله
المعارك قادمه معارك عنيفه
وانا لا ارى اي اي سبق لتغيير هذا الوضع
مفيش هناك تفاوض
يعني الخصم والعسكري مطروح
صعبه
بالضبط
[موسيقى]
يقعد تعبر من جانب روسي مؤسف صار فيه خطا
او ما بعرف شو
ولا احكي هذا الحادث لا يغير شيء على
الاطلاق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
نحن نجد بالموجود مبارزه مدفعيه ولكن
روسيا ترتكب هناك جرائم حرب وايباده
الجماعيه عندما روسيا تقصف بشكل عجيب
مدينه
كمان تستخدم
بان موجود تعزيز تعزيز القوات
من جانب روسي وكمان من جانبه اوكراني ولكن
حاول تصريحات السيد حول هذا الصاروخ
متطورنا بصفه عامه روسيا متخلفه تكنولوجيا
جدا جدا
اسلحه متطوره في وقت لراهن مستحيل روسيا
وهذا صاروخ سركوني لن
هو الحقيقه كان روسيا هي طرق وهي طفاشل
وتدريجيا هذا حرب هنا طيب الوضع صعب ولكن
نحن امام التصعيد ربما محتمل كما يمكن ان
يكون العكس اولا احييك احيي فريق العمل
والمحورين الكرام وكل من يتابعونا بمناسبه
العام الجديد نتمنى للجميع عام افضل فيه
حروب اقل وسلام اكثر
الاهم همم انه كل حرب يجب ان تنتهي ولكن
على ما يبدا على ما يبدو تتجاوز حرب
اوكرانيا العاشر ولا نجد بوادر بالطبع
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الروسيه ردا على
سؤالك لم تنجح لكنها لم ترجع يعني هذا
الفرق بمعنى او باخر ما شرحه المحاور
الكريم من موسكو انه حسب وجهه نظر القياده
الروسيه عده مراحل وما شرحه المحاور من
اوكرانيا ان هناك
الاوكراني لهذه الخطط الروسيه في حقيقه
المطاف بالطبع يعني الرهان الروسي الاول
اللي هي على حرب سريعه فقط بسرعه
لها لكن بعد ماذا بعد نجاح هجوم اوكراني
مضاد صادق على خير
وبالفعل يعني هناك ملاحظه مهمه اليوم الكل
في الاوساط العسكريه الاوروبيه يتكلم عن
فردا اوكرانيه في باخمت يعني هناك عشرات
الاشخاص هناك موت كبير في بخموت للروس
والاوكرانيين على حد سواء في على صراع على
مدينه لم ينتهي اذا حتى في الدومباز
التقدم اذا كان من قبل الروس بطيء بطيء
جدا الهجمات الاوكرانيه المضاده ايضا لا
تنجح هناك ماسك يعني يجب الاعتراف ويجب
الاعتراف برايه بان الدعم الغربي
الاوكرانيا مهما استمر لن يستمر مديدا
وبان روسيا قوه نوويه لن تسلم بالخساره
لكن ايضا الحسم الروسي مستعد يعني لا يمكن
للامريكان للاطلسيين وهم ياخذون مجابه
عالميه مع روسيا انطلاقا من اوكرانيا ان
يدعوا اوكرانيا
افشل ازاء ما يعتبروه حسب القانون الدولي
غزوه روسيه لاوكرانيا بينما روسيا لا
تزالت السر على اعتباره عمليه خاصه علما
ان غموض الاهداف ان كان من جانب موسكو او
من جانب واشنطن يعقد الوصول الى الحل لانه
همم لانه حتى الان حتى لم يقل الرئيس
بوتين انه سيكتفي بالكرم والمناطق الاربعه
التي ضمها و بالنسبه لواشنطن لا نعلم الى
اي مدى يمكن ان يذهب دعمها لهجره طيب اعود
الى ضيفه من موسكو ريكسوندرياس سكين طبعا
خطا ربوديه تتحدث هنا عن الدعم الغربي
ولكن الدعم الجديد الذي حصل هو في اتصال
هاتفي بينما كروما وزيلانسكي وهو عاده
بدبابات قتاليه خفيفه من نوع اكس
لاوكرانيا دون تحديد الموعد هل هذا يعني
ان الغرب يدرك بان هناك حاله ضعف لدى
الجيش الروسي وانا وحان الوقت
للمزيد من اوكرانيا دي ربما ارغام روسيا
على التفاوض والتواصل الى حل
اه نحن نعتقل عنه مثل معقول انه الخصم
العسكريه الموتروخ ولسه همم
نهايه الحرب اخرى
وراهم ان يكون هناك
المشيط والمشيط من المصاعدات الغربيه
لوكرانيا
من جانب روسيه يكون تركيز على الصناعه
عسكريه روسيه التي تشتغل الى المناره
بثلاثه دورات
ولا يزود الجبهه بيقول معه المطلوب وهذا
ممكن ان يستمر طويلا
وصحيح انه كانت منذ الاول من السياسه
الروسيه او صناعه روسيه لان تتحمل هذه
الاعضاء ولكن يبدو انه
في الخال والصناع العسكريه عم تشتغل اه
بشكل جيد
فبالتالي انه ااه منهاجي
روسيه همم يجري تجري من كل النواه خير من
ناحيه عديد القوات المسلحه
والقدرات العسكريه للجيش
يعني انا توجد خشيه حتى لدى الاوكرانيين
لان الان حتى في وسائل الاعلام بدات
التساؤلات حتى في الغرب الى متى ستستمر
هذه الحرب
وعليكم جميل نحن نادركوا بان هذه خارطه
بصراحه هي سوف تكون طويله نحن نشهد بان
روسيا تحقق اعاده التوجيه
اقتصادها على على حاره ناصر
من التراث
يعني
[موسيقى]
السلام هدف ساسي عن دروس
بتاريخ خشن ضروري يعني نتغير نظام في
اوكرانيا كان انتظار نهايه من جانبوت ولكن
بعض كل شهر روسيا تقلل اهدافها اولا هل
يحتل الجنوب وبعد ذلك هذا الاحتلال فاكهه
بدون باس ولكن الان نحن نجد يعني الجيش
روسي
احتلال حتى كل منطقه الباص ولكن بالعكس في
منطقه الباص في محافظه لوغانس كما موجود
بالعكس تقدم تخفيف قوات المسلحه اوكرانيه
مدينه
يعني بصفه طعمها هذا ليست مؤذي كل يوم كل
طرفين تعزز قواتها لهجوم همم جديد روسي
همم تحقق تعبيه الجزئيه او حتى تعبئه
العامه ولكن هذا لا يصعد لروسيا الان هذا
حارب
عموماجيات المتطوره هذا خارجات متطوره همم
كل حاجه لقصف الميس اللي في مكيف ميدو
اخرى همم سوف تكون حاجات عديده منها في
اقرب وقت كما انا كنت قابل نحن نشد بان
بصفه عامه هذا كمان
الحرب المدافع خاصه في جنوب بكره يعني نحن
نجهدوا هذا ممتاز
مناسبه سوف تحصل من غرب على الدبابات
خفيفه وثقيله ولكن قبل الحصول على كل هذه
المعادات عسكريه اوكرانيا تحتاج لبناء
دنيا عسكريه لاستخدام هذه المواد العسكريه
يعني الورشات اكيد هذا تحتاج وكمان تحتاج
الى وقت لتدريب الجنود باستخدام همم
غربيه يعني بصفه عامه
للاسف الشديد هي سوف تكون طويله لان هدف
ساسي بوتيم هذا الاحتلال والاكرام
هذه الحرب الطويله ولا تخشى اوكرانيا ايضا
من ان يعني رغم الكلام عن ان الروس عندهم
يعني تكنولوجيه اقل و صواريخهم لكن مع كل
هل التهويل الذي حصل بالنووي اذا قفزت هذه
الحرب الى ما بعد الربيع القادم الى الصيف
الا تخشى اوكرانيا من رده فعل الروسيه
كبيره همم لتوسيع نطاق هذه الحرب او ربما
لحسمها كما كان يقول السفير من موسكو
بصفه عامه من الممكن روسيا سوف تحقق تعبير
العامه
[موسيقى]
ااه عندي شواغل جديه بين سوف تكون الضغط
من غرب على اوكرانيا لموافقات على روسيا
همم ولكن هنا مهم بان كما قال امريكا يعني
امريكيه وكمان بريطانيه
مفاوضات مهروسه ولكن ليست على الشروط
روسيه ولكن على الشروط الاوكرانيه شروط
اوكرانيه هي طبيعيه
تحدث عن مرحله الاولى مرحله ثانيه مرحله
ثالثه
مراحل ولا ندري كيف ستكون المرحله الرابعه
وال مرحله
كل هذا نعم ربما هناك خطا عند الفريقين
يعني كما اتضح هناك خطط عند الفريقين
لهاجمات وهجمات
وفروا وتوسيع النطاق لكن في النهايه كما
قلت يعني من الصعب
في هذه الحرب كسب هذه الحرب في الاساس ليس
من ليس يعني فقط روسيا يعني امريكا اول
قوه عسكريه في العالم لم تكسب الحرف
العراق لم تكسب الحرف في افغانستان الحرب
في الصومال لنراها من متى بدات في اليمن
في سوريا في ليبيا يعني الحروب هذه الايام
ليست كما في الماضي تغيرت مع التكنولوجيا
مع المسيارات مع كل ما هذا ما هو حديث
يعني احتلال دول لم يعد نزهه كما كان في
الماضي ولذلك يجب تغيير العقليه وتغيير
الذهنيه والعوده الى الحوار يعني في
النهايه نعم الاستراتيجيه في الماضي همم
احد الاستراتيجيين الامريكيين قال ابو
بوضوح ان روسيا زائد اوكرانيا تساوي قوه
عظمى لكن روسيا من دون اوكرانيا قوه كبرى
وبالفعل يثبت ان اوكرانيا كانت مهمه جدا
بالنسبه للاتحاد السوفيتي ولكن الان
اكرانيا اخذت طلع لها وروسيا الجديده
اعطتها هذا الاستقلال المشكله هي الاغنيه
المشكله هي فعلا هي بين اخوه اعداء ولكن
مشكله مصير دوله مستقله
وكان هناك تساؤل يعني في منتصف التسعينات
عندما حصل اتفاق في على ما اظن في بودابست
حول موضوع همم اوكرانيا ونزع سلاحها
النووي لماذا يومها مثلا لم تتحمس واشنطن
وتضمها الى حلف شمال الاطلسي كما ضمت
بولندا وغيرها تركت اذا الاوكراني على
قارئه الطريق تركت حتى تماس والان بعد
الثورات الملونه بعد كل ما جرى في 2005
2014 تستخدم الجبهه الاوكرانيه كنقطه
انطلاق المجابه عالميه اذن انا مع الحق
الاوكراني لكن ما اخشاه ان هناك استخدام
للمسرح الاجرامي لغايه
تحرير اوكرانيا من الوجود الروسي
وضعيه او ذهنيه المواطن الروسي حيل ما
يجري عندما يرى عدد القتلى خاصه ما حصل ما
حصل قبل ثلاثه ايام هل هناك تغير في
العقليه محاوله لفاهم على الاقل الى متى
الى اين تسير هذه الاسراتيجيه العسكريه
للقياده الروسيه
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا الموضوع
وشيء ثالث انه صحيح اين هناك اهداف لهذه
الخارقه
[تصفيق]
غير واضح الجيش الامريكي فشل مرارا وتكرار
في الدول العديده
الله ما يجري الان في اوكرانيا وما هو
المطروخ اللهم
قد ينجح الجيش الروسي
فين هجوم خلال او في المعارك خلال الاشهر
القادمه
فعلها معرفه
الله الشعب في روسيا يعرف عنه اهداف الله
نظام اوكراني
الوصول الى موسكو
والتفكير الروسيه
بالجهود المشتركه اوكرانيه والغربيه
لروسيا فبالتالي هناك يكون او انتصار
روسيا او انتصار الغرب واكرهانيا
عبر التاريخ عبر التاريخ الطويل يعني لم
نسمع ابدا يعني عن انطلاق هجوم من
اوكرانيا ربما استخدمت استخدم الممر
الاوكراني لكن الاوكرانيا بالذات لم تهاجم
روسيا يوما
الووو اوكراني اصبح دوله مستقله لبعض
التفاعل كليه
ذلك الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
هناك الكتاب الاول للرئيس الاوكراني
اوكرانيا ليست روسيا يعني مفهوم شو
الانطلاق لسياسه الاوكرانيه منذ بدايه
التسعينات همم
خط الان هذا كانت مشيره مستمر من شيء الى
الاسود بيضبط له روسي
وجبه الناظر الروسيه اوكرانيا غربي
[موسيقى]
على كل خجيج طول عريض حول الموضوع بس هذا
ابدا الى هذه الخرب همم
ومعروفه انه همم بالنسبه لروشيا الصمم
الاساسي هنا مصيردوا باصي لكان صمانيا
سنوات تحتها القصر الاخرى طيب الان ما
يجري همم يعتبر كانه هذا يعني الله مستقبل
وجود روسي
[موسيقى]
هزيمه روسيه
خلاص لم تكون روسيه بخارطه العالم اذا تم
الانتصار الروسيه فهذا يعني همم
روسيا افشل خطه الغربيه
عينيها الله
تسيطر فيها القوى القوميه الراديكاليه همم
وروسيا ستنتصر طيب ولا ضمير انت بالتاكيد
تعرف العقليه الروسيه اكثر مني واكثر من
خطار ابو دياب
يعني بالنظر الى ما حصل
مؤخرا ومقتل هذا العدد الكبير من الجنود
هل تعتقد ان ان فلاديمير بوتين سيظل مكتوف
الايدي في الفتره المقبله
مره ثانيه ولكن مهم جدا بان اوكرانيا
مدبلج
بريطانيا امريكا
في نهايه المطاف والاطراف
بصراحه انا موافق بصفه عامه اوكرانيا
رهينه
روسيا ولكن عندما هجم على اوكرانيا وهو
وصل في نفسه
هذا ممتازه روسي استخدمت كديه النهضه
انضمامه
وكمان بيعمل تقريبا منذ السنه علي انا همم
امين العام الناطق بان اوكرانيا لن تدخل
في الناتو في اقرب 10 سنوات ولكن عليها
رغم انها بتصريحات روسيا هاجمه طالب
اوكرانيا لان هدف صح عشان ده روسيا هذا
الاحتلال اكيد اكيد ليست ضد الباص ولكن
الروس
مستشار السابق لحاتم وحافظته خير ان نحن
نجمع كل يوم اجله من جرائم حرب روسيا هذا
يمين تقع للاسف شديد يعني بصفه طعمه كمان
موجود كمان نحن شاهدنا في جنوب اوكرانيا
موجود
قوات المسلحه روسيه روسيه لا يعرفون لماذا
يحاربون هنا في اوكراني الان جنوب
اوكرانيا اكيد
هذا هؤلاء باقوال شعب اوكراني
وخسائر بالمناسبه روسيه هي ضخمه ولكن سلطه
روسيه لا تهتم على اخصاء بالمناسبه عن دار
روسيا استراتيجيه السوفيتي في هذا الحرب
روسيا تحتاج لتغير الاستراتيجيه بصفه عامه
ولكن لتغير
السلطه
الان يرغبون انه يعرف روسي واكيد عندما
روسيا سوف توفاشل هذا حرب سوف تكون اولا
سقوط النظام وابعد ذلك
اذا اردنا نسمع ذلك يعني انه ليس هناك من
مخرج من هذه الحرب ليس هناك من خروج
والطبع يعني اذا
وصلنا الان لنقيم حصيله العام 2022 من هذه
الحرب يمكن ان نقول ان واشنطن وبكين
تكسبان هما بعدتان نسبيا ولو انه ماتت
فعان بعض الخسائر ونرى كيف يبقى موقف
الصين حذرا بينما تدمر اوكرانيا وروسيا
يعني تتراجع واوروبا ايضا تعاني اذا في
النهايه هناك من هو رابح ومن هو خاسر
وربما تراهن روسيا على ان اوروبا ستبدا
بالصراخ على ان الغرب لن يستمر بالصمود
لكن الان اصبحت اوكرانيا نوعا من خط
الدفاع الامامي امامي على الغرب ولد مهما
طالت الحرب سيكون هناك الزام معنوي من قبل
الغرب
مهما طلب ومهما دفعت اوروبا من اثمان
ولذلك لابد من البناء
والجلوس الى التفاوض ولكن بشكل عقلاني
يعني يجب ان يكون هناك تنازلات في النهايه
لا تستمر اي حرب الى اللانهايه اذا بقي
التفكير منحصرا عند موسكو بكيفيه اسقاط
النظام في الكاف وعند النظام في كاف
بكيفيه اسقاط بوتين في موسكو عند ذلك يمكن
كما قلت ان تنزلق هذه الحرب الى ما هو
اوسع من المسرح الاوكراني يعني هناك
بولندا ويمكن ان تتورط اذا تتورطت بلا
روسيا مثلا وهذا يعني هنا وهذا يعني ان
الاطلس يمكن ان يتورط وهذا وارد وكل هذا
يعني ان روسيا يمكن ان تستخدم عند ذلك
اسلحه غير تقليديه لا اعرف ما هي هذه
الاسلحه حتى الان هناك نوع من الاستهتار
حول الموضوع ولكن عندما نرى جنون في تلك
ناحيه من اقصى شرق اسيا عبر مراتي نعلم ان
هناك نوعا من التهميش لخطوره السلاح
النووي
وهذا التهميش يمكن ان يؤدب العالم الى
الكارثه وان ننتقل من المجابه العالميه
الى الحرب العالميه الثالثه لا اريد ان
يكون في بدايه هذا العام غرابه شام لكن
اذا استمرت هذه الحرب هذه الحرب لن تتوقف
عند حدود اوكرانيا وروديمير تفضل تريد ان
تفاعل مع خطار تفضل
تنازلها تنازلها الان هذا من المستحيل
الان سنه 2014 روسيا هجمت غادرنا
الاوكرانيا احتاجت الجلوس
خلقه هناك الجمهوريتين غير متعرفتين بها
في هذه المنطقه تقابل روسيا احتار لا
توصلك من اوكرانيا شبه جزيره القرم بصفه
عامه كانت تنازلات ولكن شهيه تونسيه هي
الداخمه
جزيره الكرم ايام التحسس ياتي
هذا هذا اسطوره روسيه بدي صراحه ريال هناك
بصراحه هناك شعب الحقيقي الاصلي هناك هو
قطار
جدا
في سنه 2008
خالد
اليوم امس كانت جورجيا اليوم بعد بكره
اخرى
بهذه الطريقه
[موسيقى]
بالمناسبات
من الرؤساء
حتى في الغرب الذين يدعمونا اوكرانيا لابد
من الابقاء على قناه تواصل مع بلادي
بورتين لابد من عدم استفزاز روسيا في هذه
الحرب اذا هناك مواقف مختلفه عما تقول حتى
من قبل الدول التي تدعم اوكراني
من مكرون ولكن يعني انه
رؤساء اخر كمان يدركون يعني
[موسيقى]
الجو او
لتجميد اوروبا وكمان
روسيا تهدده بشكل دائم استخدام اسلحه
نوويه وسيدنا وليس السابق وهو بشكل دائم
كمان يهاجدده باستخدام هذه الاسلحه بالصفه
عامه همم للاسف شديد حار هي سوف تكون
طويله ونحن تدخلنا في عصر ال- ال- الزمالك
هذا الخطاب بالتاكيد تقرا ايضا الصحف
الاوكرانيه تتابع بالتاكيد حتى القنوات
الاوكرانيه يعني دخلنا في دواء من حوار
الطرشان
والله شيء غريب انه نحن في روسيا نحترم
تقاليد الصوفيتي والصداقه الشعوب
الان في اوكرانيا يكرهون العهد السوفيتي
راحوا انه
القياصر الروسوار
واخرجوا
الصلاه
الله اكبر
طيب والله في كل الاحوال
شو بتصير الله خلال الفتره القادمه
نحن لا نرى مخرج اخر
الله
كانه صراع وجودي
اربعه مناطق التي
اصبحت جزء من الروسيه
مثلا الله اوكرانيا الغربيه
نحن نعيش في دوله واحده
ولكن ولكن الله
هناك النهايه الحرب هذا همم هذه هي
المشكله الاساسيه همم لانه همم لانه الغرب
يستخدم
الاوكرانيه ضد روسيا ولو بقيت هناك جزء
بسيط من الاراضي فيستمر هذا الاستخدام
فلذلك اين هناك يعني نقطه نهايه لها همم
وحتى الان لا اتصور ان همم
له روسيا
واوكراني شيء مقبول
لترفه
هذا السؤال مفتوح وما فيش هناك يعني هناك
اراء طرحت مثلا طرح كيسنجر وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاسباب
طرح فكره بان يتم الانسحاب العسكري الى
خطوط فما قبل 24 فبراير اي عمليه ان تبقى
روسيا في شبه جزيره الكره حتى اشعار اخر
تم رفض ذلك من قبل الروس ومن قبل
الاوكرانيين وقال الرئيس لينسكي انه يريد
ان يسمح في مياه القرم في الصيف القادم
اذا
هكذا منطق الاقتراحات الغربيه حتى
بالضمانات كما تكلم مكروه عن ضمرات امنيه
رفضت ايضا اذا هناك نوع من ماززق وهذا
الماء زق سيستمر اذا لم يكن هناك من افكار
جديده لمحاوله ايجاد مخرج قبل فوات الاوان
بالمناسبه بعض كلام ميركل انه اتفاقات مين
كان فقط
لتمهيد الجيش الاوكراني للحرب مع روسيه
خلاص انه لم يعود في روسيا ثقه بي اي
اتفاق في ظروف الراهنه مع اوكرانيا او
الضمانات الغربيه
والروسه
حوالي 700 شخص
يعني بصفه طعمها
شباب هو حتى يعني كل هذا يعني
هناك في جنوب اوكرانيا هذا غير مقبول بصفه
عامه واكيد ان نحن هنا في اوكرانيا
انتقام اليرموس وتبقى اكيد انهرغبوا ان هي
اتحاد روسي وسقوط النظام استبدالي بوتين
طيب بالنسبه للجرائم الحركه سنرى في
المستقبل همم بعض تحقيق هذا اول شيء
الثاني انه انا مقتنع تماما عدم استخدام
السلاح النووي في الاوكرانيا وصالصه انا
مقتنع عن حرب لم تتوسع الى الخطوط همم
اوسع من خطوط اوكرانيه يعني لم يتم
التصادم همم بين جيش الروسي والناطه
هذه نقطه ايجابيه وهو هذا واضح ان الجانب
الامريكي حتى الان يتفادى ايضا منح
اوكرانيا اي سلاح يمكن ان يصل الى الاراضي
الروسيه سنرى مع البتريوت اذا كان سيكون
هناك من تغيير في هذا الموضوع ام لا وكذلك
روسيا وبين ذلك مساله الصاروخ نحو بولندا
روسيا ايضا تبدو حريصه على عدم توسيع ذلك
لكن هذا حتى الان نظري
الخطوره انه اذا استمرت الحرب هذا
الانزلاق يمكن ان شخص صغير يمكن ان يحصل
خطا يسبب انزلاق ويمكن ان تحصل خسائر
كبيره عند الطرف لا يتحملها لذلك نحن هناك
لاعب
على حافه الهاويه طيب كيف تنظر الان الى
المواقف الدوليه لان في فتره معينه كنا
نسمع دائما بيانات في الفتره الاخيره خاصه
المجتمع الدولي في نوع من الترجي يعني
المجتمع الدولي كانه تعود على هذه الحرب
وعلى استمرارها لكن المهم انه حصل لقاء
اخير او قمه اخيره بين الصين وروسيا
عن بعد ولا نلبه حتى الان نوعا من حلف
استراتيج السيني روسي هناك تنسيق الصين
نتيجه مصالحها الكبرى مع الغرب تبقى بعيده
وتريد ايضا ان تاخذ وقتها لكي تستعد لانها
هي ربما تعتقد ان نقطه الانطلاق من
اوكرانيا يمكن ان تصل لها في تايوان في
بحر الصين في اماكن اخرى الصين تبدو حذره
وهذا يضع فلوسها التي اضطرت حتى لجلب
طائرات من دون طيار من ايران يعني هذه
نقطه فشل الصناعه العسكريه الروسيه مهما
كانت هذه الطائرات قليله الثمن لكن من
ناحيه اخرى حتى الهند الدوله التي تستورد
الكثير من روسيا تطلب من روسيا وقف الحرب
في النهايه
اعتقد ان معسكر الاستمرار بالحرب من قبل
الجانبين سيتضاءا مع الوقت يعني لن يتحمل
الجانب الغربي الدعم العسكري المديد
لاوكرانيا ولم يتحمل الحلفاء روسيا او من
هم وقفوا ضد العقوبات مع روسيا دعم الموقف
الروسي اذا اصرت روسي على استمرار الحرب
لابد في لحظه ما من الوصول الى ما نسميه
نقطه التوازن للانطلاق الى المفاوضات ربما
الان سيكون هناك تصعيد لكي يحاول كل طرف
تحسين اوراق اهو لكن اظن ان الرئيس بوتين
رغم كل شيء يعطي علامات تفاوض والرئيس
رزقي رغم الخطاب العالي عندما تقول له
واشنطن تفاهه والسيد تفاوض ولذلك
من حيث المبدا يجب ان يكون منتصف العام
2023 مدخلا لانهاء هذه الحرب والا بتقدير
يمكن لهذه الحرب ان تذهب نحو الاسوه طيب
انت تعتقد بان هذا السيناري وارد الذي
يتحدث عنه خطر بوديات
الجبهه التي
تستقر اليوم لن تكون مستقره ربما بعد
الصبيح او بعض اشهر
فهذا هو الله همم يعني تطور اللاحق للوضع
الشكر في الختام لخطر ابو دياب استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه الشكر من كيب لبرج
الامير شوماكوف دبلوماسيوكراني سابق
والشكر من موسكو اليكساندر ساكين
وديبلوماسي روسي سابق الشكر لفريق
البرنامج حمصي مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]